I'd like to start by doing a grounding
exercise so I'd like for us to just
close our eyes and TuneIn word a couple
deep breaths inward and outward another
one inward and now
I don't want us to really deeply feel
the heart inside of our bodies so
magical organ that beats a hundred
thousand times a day keep us alive
just really tap into that heartbeat for
a little bit try and feel the heartbeat
sometimes slow breaths in and out can
help you feel the heartbeat
and now I want you to visualize a will
go upward first from the body want to
have you go from your feeling of your
own body out through the top of your
head and out into the size of city of
Sioux Falls feel the city of Sioux Falls
then I want you to go further feel the
entire state of South Dakota feel the
country and feel the whole planet and
stay with that feeling of you being as
expansive as the whole planet
and go out one more to the universe you
are the universe remember to keep that
breath going
[Music]
and now let's go back from the universe
to earth to the country to the state
Sioux Falls to your body and now let's
go into the organ so let's go into the
heart feel the heart go again in feel
the cell feel an individual cell in your
heart now feel the molecule in that cell
feel the atom that makes up that
molecule feel the electrons the protons
and neutrons feel the quarks feel that
Planck volume the smallest measurable
volume you are that from the Planck
volume all the way up to the universe
and the human in between you are that in
every moment in time from your birth has
been a playing card and it's just been
stacking up visualize it with me stack
up every moment in time has been a
playing card since you were one year old
one one year one day in one minute and
one second old and then one day one one
year one day one minute two seconds old
every single one's a little playing card
and on those playing cards sometimes
are difficult situations but we're in
love with those so be in love with every
moment in time from your past and every
moment of your future and the present
and feel in love with that past that
present in that future and you being on
that divine path on your divine path
all right thank you everyone for joining
me in that grounding